effort to make sure he got back so they
couldn't make that last pass
defensively and then tracking down the
loose ball and then not letting it get
thrown off of it
six point lead in the ball
steph thought about that step back clay
won't think at all
21 for klay thompson was there ever a
doubt
as soon as clay got it he's letting it
fly look at him smiling this is what i
do this is my mo i make those types of
shots
but the thunder crowd over the years
they're like not that guy again look at
looney though the effort
the smarts made sure he saved it
found
steph and steph is about to take giddy
but he decides to give it to his splash
brother he knows what to do with it
and for baisley that's a mental error
why are you off of klay thompson there
i mean just if you're playing the
warriors giddy was right up with steph
you can't you gotta have somebody other
than those two guys beat you any space
is too much space there and i think
steph just caught him off guard bailey
must not have thought steph was going to
pass it
he was trying to make sure he was